it's honestly being crazy because like
obviously i'm
i'm still a student so like i have to
rely on my parents
like financially so
it was kind of like they're like you
gotta quit engineering and either do
something related with that so and and
you're obviously trying to like sneak in
like like your daily salad and all that
right
and it's kind of like it kind of gets
obvious at one point like when
because we look and i'm in a muslim
country and when the time goes off and i
literally just goes close to the storage
room and just
just stay there for for like 10 minutes
it's pretty obvious
always let yourself grow man like i
remember like
i was a little bit too egoistic when i
became a agreement like i thought i knew
everything like
and then when like people used to tell
me oh do you know this is in the quran
this is like i never knew that
obviously just um never never think that
you know enough
and keep going and like like find a
support system because
bro like i have people like
who always used to reach out to me back
in virginia and
like i have nobody to teach me prayers
anything and these guys will
not reward them but dude these guys were
like patient with me and they
they helped me so like like if you're
planning to take this step
go to your local mosque like find some
nice brothers over there who could help
you out
nice brothers or sisters um could help
you out
and yeah man and just just remember it's
a journey
[Music]
you know you can do this without school
you already know that you can bring in
money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life
for you to go to college so you can get
this degree and
make this money whereas bro i keep
preaching this
you don't need school if you don't need
school if you're not trying to be a
doctor you're not trying to be a lawyer
you're not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer
right not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you could do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in ribba in interest in student
loans
you are now tuned in to the t3m podcast
welcome back
this is our first many episodes insha
allah
telling the stories of our lovely
brothers and sisters today on the show
we got brother kenneth he will be the
first insha allah
from episode 24 when we mention that we
will be taking
our lovely brothers and sisters in islam
who reverted and allowing them to share
their lovely
beautiful stories with us welcome
kenneth to the ttm podcast how are you
doing today man
i'm good i'm good how are you
alhamdulillah we are doing good
and i'm excited about to hear about your
story today insha'allah so why don't you
introduce yourself in your background
yes so i'm 21 years old i'm
a college student i'm doing mechanical
engineering at the moment
uh i studied in i i mean i'm studying in
virginia us uh i'm originally from
india uh and uh what do you say
uh like southern part of india like it's
it's a state called
kerala and like funnily enough it's like
like our ethnic our dress is like noogie
which like
i know fire's pretty familiar with it
yeah and uh release i was born in a
christian hospital and uh
so the the community is called
marthomads so it's
it's it's believed to be descended from
saint thomas who is like who was like
the apostle of
like a disciple of jesus who came to
india
after like christ was crucified and
everything and apparently he was the one
who spread christianity
and like the people who he spread chris
on christianity too
they're really called martha white so
that's like
i guess that's like my family background
yeah masha allah so you come from a
christian household then
yeah yeah my
my uh my uncle's father is a priest
my my grandmother's cousin is a
bishop my my grandfather's cousin is a
bishop
i myself served as an altar boy like in
a lot of the church services yeah so
yeah we were pretty traditional
christians yeah
and i'm sure we'll get to um you know
your your family and their part in your
conversion and where they stand
insha'allah in your story so
uh what was your first interaction with
islam and how did you feel about it
initially
uh i was feeling my first interaction
with
islam was like oh when i was like
probably
in first to second year we had like
these uh general knowledge books in
india
and uh we said um like i obviously read
the bible
and i was pretty well versed with the
bible like the basics like
at that age so i knew that angel gabriel
came to mother mary to inform
that's that's what wrote in the bible
too right so
when it said that uh gabriel came to
mohammed i was like boy
it's like bro like he just started
starting a new religion now
i kind of have that like mindset like
when he just
he's angel group was going to another
religion
i didn't know anybody i was like maya
it's the final last kind of allah it's
kind of funny to be honest so you
thought the angel just kind of like
converted or something
because you start a new religion yeah
subhanallah
so um when you begin to learn that um
muslims believe christianity was
corrupted and that's why islam came down
as a reminder of what was previously
sent how did you feel about that when
you first learned about it
um please i was not surprised honestly
because i kind of knew that christianity
was like our books weren't preserved
because we actually learned that in san
diego
which was like we we got to know that
our
what do you say the the mean uh
the book the bible is divided into old
testament and new testament right so
old testament we care from jewish
sources like the torah
um and like other books like
ecclesiastes
song of songs psalms all of this song
all of those chapters and the new
testaments we get by
individual accounts and like
you can see like like they see that
they taught they taught us that like
even though they have like differing
accounts
like it's like one it's like one source
basically so
and they kind of like told her taught us
how to reconcile with the fact that
there might be different endings to the
chapters and everything yeah
awesome they're a very honest sunday
school
uh saying that you know yeah it was
corrupted it was changed a lot
um obviously it was corrupting
yeah yeah allah
when did you actually take your shahada
was it more recently or
it was like i think uh one and a half
years ago so like
i was 19 back then
so what led up to your actual conversion
when you said okay call us this is it i
know this is the truth and you accepted
it
um like honestly like
like i always was attracted towards
islam because uh
so i just give you a brief back story
like uh
like my family just keeps moving around
like i've been in around like from
preschool to
the completion of high school i've been
in around eight schools
so like we keep moving around so that
the plus point of that is that we got to
meet a lot of cultures
like interact with a lot of people and
you don't like
like you don't actually like uh be
comfortable with one this thing like you
always like
uh interact with new people so it's like
you always get that
new exposure so
so i had lived in like before moving to
us for college i had
lived in the middle east for dubai and
qatar for like
around six years yeah so
like i had muslim friends and like but i
i obviously didn't know
like like they used to pray and all of
that
but i i knew pretty much the basics
but it was really until like college
then i
when you say i actually did that step
because
i because like my like said
of when i came to america like the
christianity practice in america was
like totally different
than the one we practiced in in india
because
like our this thing is a little bit more
traditional like like there's not many
songs
there's you know and even though we the
recite are like certain
prayers it's very similar to like how
you would recite the quran
uh so um
yeah so i kind of like like when you're
going from that
environment and like you can't like walk
in with your
the shoes inside the women their heads
are covered
all of this stuff like and then you go
to a church where like it's literally
like a rock concert it's like
like i'm just like that was like a huge
culture shock
like like it can't move my mind so
like i actually like distant myself from
that church
and like i still used to go to church
and
like just just sit there just like just
draw just just to be all peaceful and
still pray to god and uh
yeah and i actually forgot to mention
one thing um
like in what he says we have uh
like in a good friday service like being
also like
we prostrate our heads and do the
surgery and so like it's
it's it's kind of like pretty much
similar so like when i converted it was
like
this was it like because i've been doing
it and i remember whenever i used to do
the
prostitution during the good friday
service i was like
like i wish i could do more but i
obviously couldn't because it's
it's really it's really like a special
thing like
that like when i got to islam and
like doing it every day it's like it's
pretty serious honestly
so you were almost behaving like a
muslim before you were muslim
and then you saw these connections right
like oh they prayed like this reaper
like this right there
um eventually like that and our events
are like this kind of allah
so um it's really good to hear that um
there are still surviving pieces of what
you know jesus
was really like and what he really did
in
certain practices in in some
denomination christianity today
alhamdulillah
because i feel like that's a bonus for
us being able to say
you know muslims are more like jesus
than than a lot of christians nowadays
alhamdulillah
it's found allah so what was your
conversion like and did you tell your
family right away or did it take some
time
definitely not that like i
didn't know until like two months like
like two months back like the garden
with this this year and it's been like
it's honestly being crazy because like
obviously i'm
i'm still a student so like i have to
rely on my parents
like financially so
it was kind of like they're like you
gotta equate engineering and either do
something related with that so and
and you're obviously trying to like
sneak in like like your daily salad and
all that right
and it's kind of like it kind of gets
obvious at one point like when
because we're
just just stay there for for like
10 minutes it's pretty obvious for them
too and they
and then they let me you know like be
before me converting to islam we used to
pray like two times a day
like one in the morning one in the night
so
i start i stopped going for the i mean i
stopped coming like
the main room for the like prayers and
it was like yeah man so they they always
had like
there was a lot of friction and like
honestly i kind of understand their
viewpoint because like if
i had kids and suddenly they just
converted to buddhism or something
obviously be annoyed too so yeah it is
what it is
yes so uh before i go on fire do you
have any questions anything to add
man that was subhanallah man thank you
so much for sharing that
so i had two questions my first one
would be how did you find our podcast
i think honestly like when
reverted and then he said that he was
launching a podcast bro i've been on the
lookouts ever since then and when you
guys
launched episode one two i probably
might have been like
100 to like 100 to the first
1000 people to watch it probably yeah
definitely yeah and what are your
thoughts on the podcast so far have you
are you caught up do you like them
dude i've been i've been watching doing
an email
like i've pretty much bought up
everything yeah salah
alhamdulillah thank you for all your
support means a lot
and there's a lot of people that this
leads me into my second question a lot
of people are
watching on how's video they're like
what is this whole thing about islam
i used to learn about them from fox news
or i used to learn about them from you
know the media
and now that we see brother angel who i
used to relate to he's muslim now
this seems very like interesting so they
start watching our podcast
right they they watch a few episodes in
they watch
rami you know spitting facts giving his
philosophy giving
a lot of the arguments that you know are
kind of unrefutable and
it makes sense they resonate with him
they resonate with me they resonate with
angel
they feel a part of them which we know
is the fitra kind of accepting islam
but they're kind of in the shoes that
you were in right before you you did
your shahada they have all these
thoughts coming in should i do it what
about my family
you know if i do what if i don't like it
or
shouldn't i become the perfect muslim
before i take the step why should i just
do the shahada if i'm
imperfect if i didn't even learn or
finish the quran right
what is your message to all these people
um obviously like uh uh
go go to the source material like i'm
pretty sure aniel said that a lot
like just go to the source material
learn from
i mean sorry in the quran like i
remember like the first time i ever read
the quran
like i was just i was just like
just in that zone like like i read the
bible and the bible has like
i mean there's like beneficial knowledge
in it but like it's there's a lot it's
not like
it's not like it's not like 100
beneficial it's like
there's like genealogies a lot of stuff
in
it like which is like fluff basically
but like the quran bro
it's like it's like strictly the point
it's like no
beating around the bush and yeah man
it's like it's like those wake-up calls
like
like when when you really want to change
it's like you need to have that
wake-up call and and like it gives one
biggest makeup cause in my opinion like
it shows you like how like that is not
the end of the life
and like you have like you are going to
be judged like you are going to have
like
there you might be going to hell or
heaven based on what you did
and you got to treat people right you
gotta
it goes on and on like but but the core
message
like worship just one card and have no
partners it's
i mean it's it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward you don't have to
have some logical explanation to it you
don't have to like
be able to voice in philosophy or
anything to understand that
and and that's that's really something
which i really liked about the quran
like like one of my favorite voices was
the
um i think it was chapter 2 verse 13
it was like when when allah said that
let us create and um let us create on uh
earth and authority and the angels were
like
why are you gonna create another
creation which
which are gonna shed bloodshed
corruption like
like almost like almost like it's kind
of like what we are
in right now but and then the fact that
like allah says that i know what you do
not know like
like like that like the i don't know man
like the strength
emitted from that sentence like bro it
just like shook me right
it's like it actually makes sense and it
actually shows that there is a purpose
like
even though there are people who go evil
like
use evil methods and do not go into
listening terrors
there are always gonna be those people
who are gonna
stay on the right path and gonna be an
inspiration for the huma
for the rest of humanity so that's
that's kind of inspirational in my
opinion and that that that wasn't like
all the like the voices which shook me
i'm like bro after you know i was like
there's no way i've this is not from god
because i've never read anything like
this
yeah and one more thing
i would tell um people who are looking
into islam is that
there's also like the thing about
testimonies right
so you want to like before you before
you
listen to someone you gotta like just
just look at the background
like you don't want it like you don't
want to get uh
information on biology from like someone
who is well-versed and
like astronaut astronomy or something
like that right
you wanna like get someone who's
well-versed in biology to
answer somebody for questions in biology
and like when you have like people like
anti-islamic uh
channels like these are like people who
do not speak arabic
do not know quran it's like they've
they've just
basically gathered whatever orientalist
material and
what and they just like like basically
to
just like try to fit in one video 15
minutes without explaining any context
so it's like like instead of looking at
their this thing and
watching those videos and try wasting
your time i would like
i would like highly suggest people to
just like read
find it out find out about it by
yourself you don't have to like
like look at people who obviously like
if you're going to learn about islam
you've got to go to islamic college
you're going to learn about christianity
christianity and i'm going to go to i
don't know you know i'm going to saudi
arabia or something like that right
you're going to go to christian scholars
it's pretty obvious but
like some people learn islam from
anti-islamic youtubers so it's kind of
pretty obvious what message they're
gonna put
[Music]
100 man
yo do you see romney frozen too
yeah that's that's literally like when
me and angel record
every couple episodes we get that and we
don't know what to do with it because we
don't know if he's going to come back
we don't know if he's there you know
lagged out i got this notification
saying something something else is using
using this ip and then internet was
unstable my bad i'm back though
you're good bro you're good did you get
most of what he said though yeah i got
basically everything maybe
i missed the last 10 seconds but you
don't want to go to the wrong people
for for certain information essentially
right yeah
100 100 um and
i know a lot of people have this
mentality that like oh if i go to muslim
scholars they're going to be biased
and it's like what a disrespect to the
to the profession right imagine going to
uh
to it's like a a psychologist and saying
like he says he diagnosed me with this
i think he's just biased he doesn't like
me like
who's really going to go to that extent
right and disrespect the profession to
that level if they have evidences
what are you going to say if they prove
it to you you can't really say anything
at the end of the day so 100 you have to
go to the right people
um who actually studied it don't go to
david wood
uh he doesn't think about it
he doesn't he still doesn't know a thing
about arabic i th honestly
you would think in 10 20 years of
studying islam you would at least pick
up a little
the arabic language at least the accent
or something
100 you know who you know david
of course so like like i'm the reason
i'm telling you not to like i'm telling
some of the people how to listen to like
these people is because i've actually
like
when i i knew as long as the truth bro
it was like
i knew it was the truth from my heart
but like my mind was like bro
it could be like i'm still a christian
right
like i have to like back up myself at
something right
so like you can't but the thing is that
when you watch dvd videos like you can't
know what kind of person he is
at the end of the day like even
regardless of what information he's
saying like
truth or not like you can see his
character right
and for me that speaks volumes like like
he's
he's like he's purposely misrep
misrepresenting a lot of people
like and i don't think that any religion
suppose that
um it's funny because recently he
released a video talking about the
uyghur muslims and how they're being
persecuted
and it's it's almost as if he was
standing up for the muslims um he
started off the video talking about how
christians are also being persecuted
but um subhanallah he really highlighted
uyghur muslims
but then i saw sabor ahmad made a video
saying uh you know it's great that
you're you're
calling the chinese communist government
out for what they're doing
and standing up for the uyghurs and
using your platform for that way for
that reason but
at the same time it's people like you
that push this narrative that
this this kind of stuff should happen
the muslims because you're pushing
this idea that we're backwards because
we have all these
weird backwards ways and these weird
laws and we don't have morality and the
prophet i said was this that the other
um so you can't have the cake and eat it
one of the other subhanallah but um
and the way these guys get refuted like
you would think that
like after that reputation like well
they wouldn't have zero viewers but they
still get like dozens of years probably
yeah there's a lot of a lot of islam
haters out there
um i heard a lot of their uh viewers
actually i think he was talking about it
was when we had daniel uh
on here uh he said that a lot of apus's
viewers are like from india and like
there's a lot of like islam haters over
there
if you've been following keeping up with
the news uh with what they're doing with
muslims and
and how they're persecuting them and
everything um
the truth has enemies it
yeah man with that being said i got a
question for for romney now
rami if somebody's here watching this
can it's like what the hell
uh if somebody is watching a video and
they they like what kenneth saying they
saw the the
you know the subscriber kevin our
brother from ireland who
who alhamdulillah reverted to islam and
he steadfast and may allah keep him and
you and everyone else that fast too i
mean
um and they're watching and they're like
maybe i have a story too
um but i don't know if you know is it
even interesting is it not
how do i get on rami what do you got to
say to them
um i mean reach out every everyone's
story matters
right it doesn't have to be like you
know i was climbing a mountain and i
found a quran
in this like this little cubby hole and
it doesn't have to be anything
else a lot more story you know matters
everyone's opinion matters and as long
as you have hair
to share you have good to say then come
on inshaallah
we have uh we have twitter now i think
twitter instagram
um also our email if you want to reach
out to that we also have our patreon if
you want to
get on there reach out to us let us know
what's up
and uh just chat with us a little bit
insha'allah we can get you one
what do you have to say about that man
i'll say 100
kenneth what do you got to say to that
your comments yeah 100
all right so with that being said i
think this was a very productive episode
thank you once again jazakallahu kai for
sharing your episode
uh sharing your episode sharing your
experience and story for this episode
um inshallah a lot of people can get
some wisdom can feel like they can
relate to you on an emotional level
maybe on a
on a logical rational level as well um
and to anyone watching that's kind of on
the fence
you're not supposed to stay on defense
forever there's a reason you feel this
cognitive dissonance this paradigm shift
right there's something in your heart
like brother canon said that resonates
with the truth
but your mind your ego just doesn't want
to accept it that's why i always preach
that
my belief is you become a muslim before
you become a muslim like you become a
muslim
you revert you convert to islam before
you say the shahadah
right because the shahada is just your
ego catching up it's just your ego
acknowledging you know what
maybe i am muslim but oftentimes at that
point you already know you're muslim
so if you want more you know input on
that go on our channel
we have uh in our channel home page we
have a little um tab that says new to
islam
um watch those videos uh you know look
look at reputable sources like he said
don't just go to anyone for
for you know learning about islam you
wouldn't go to a astrophysicist to learn
about biology like the brother said
so you want to go to someone that knows
about islam and like ramy said
you thinking someone who's a muslim will
be biased about islam
in and of itself is a bias against
muslims so
instead of doing two biases let's let's
cut the
let's cut the you know bs let's just go
straight to the truth let's just go
right in
and uh inshaallah uh because it is the
truth and we know it to be
um it should resonate with you at least
i can guarantee that it should
insha allah inshallah a hundred percent
facts masha allah
masha'allah um kenneth brother do you
have any last final words for the uh the
audience
before we part ways
um i guess so
oh even if you become very good i guess
just
just always let yourself grow man like i
remember like
i was a little bit too egoistic when i
became a
agreement like i thought i knew
everything like
and then when like people used to tell
me oh do you know this is in the quran
this is like whoa i never knew that
so obviously just um never never think
that you know enough
and keep going and like like find a
support system because
bro like i have people like
who always used to reach out to me back
in virginia and
like i have nobody to teach me prayers
anything and these guys will
not reward them but dude these guys were
like patient with me and they
they helped me so like like if you're
planning to take this step
go to your local mosque find some nice
brothers over there who could help you
out
nice brothers or sisters um could help
you out
and yeah man and just just remember it's
a journey bro so
and yeah it is that's the last advice
for anyone that
um because we've talked about
considering reverting to islam
people that have reverted to islam you
know you did say that you know
um don't think you know everything
because then you can't grow and improve
and learn
any other tips on how you learned
everything how you learned
praying you know how to recite uh surahs
if you know you did mention one and a
half years ago so i'm assuming you had
at least one ramadan
right just tips on how you took these
new islamic traditions
and new things you have to do
um just just take it slow man and uh
and one mistake which i did was that i
watched we
do many youtube videos and the thing is
that it
it doesn't stay in my head too much and
it's tough it just escapes my mind a lot
so like reading a lot helps me help me a
lot
uh and
yeah what was the other part of your
question i'm sorry i'm just tips tips
for people to learn like new things you
know
like you how to pray how to fast
you know just learn more and and not
just learn more but put that into their
habit into the routine
into their daily practices um maybe
things that you had to keep in mind that
now they're easy but initially you wish
you would have known this
so this is really good site called new
muslim academy
and uh i could give you guys the link so
you can attach it in the video
so they they had they have like bro they
do really good work like every month or
every week i'm not very sure like they
they have like
live paper prayer tutorials and
they show you how to pray and you have
other rewards like
i remember i met like someone from who
was nine years old
and who converted to islam and he was in
wisconsin
and his friends didn't know anything
about it and he mashallah he was like
he was already interested in learning
how to pray so like you have people
like so you can like find people who
are learning how to brand and maybe you
could like start a
like a chat with them or something like
that and
uh yeah they even cover some basic akita
courses so you could like
make sure that you have the correct
understanding
yeah perfect amazing kenneth mann thank
you for that rami before you end it off
one time what brother was saying right
now about this this
this platform you know it reminds me of
a brother i know who has a platform
himself
and would you like to share that you're
talking about me
yes sir uh yeah follow me
on my uh subscribe to my youtube channel
i guess we'll put that in the
description as well it is
and look at the handle go to my ig
in my tick tock yes you guessed it
go follow me on there inshaallah uh and
yeah
just trying to you know i'm not talking
about that
come on keep thinking keep thinking come
on man i'm gonna put you on the spot
we're not gonna cut this out either
all right all right can we get like
jeopardy music playing or something well
i think
jeopardy music playing um but i'll give
you a hint
pen a pen
even i'm lost man bro you literally
launched a platform come on
you talking about my patreon bro muslim
pen pals come on now oh muslim pen file
bro
no you know you know you know what
happened i merged it with i3
that's what happened i merged with i3 so
now it's become like an i3 initiative
and they're trying to keep it local
okay gotcha go a little bit more into
that man
so if you're in the gta before you wrap
up insha'allah if you're in the gta the
greater toronto area
then look up i3 institute insha'allah
we're going to be launching
a reverb program so anyone who accepts
islam
who needs a you know a muslim pen pal or
a mentor a friend to be there for them
teach them about islam and all that
and a place where they can take courses
have a good community
join i3 institute the letter i number
three institute dot ca inshallah that's
gonna be launching soon
i also have my own uh revert programs
called muslim pen pal
which is now being integrated with i3
for global
muslims people who are not in the area
they can still be assigned a
literal traditional pen pal even if they
aren't in the same proximity
writing back and forth to each other
being there for each other insha allah
thank you for mentioning that because it
slipped my mind for this podcast
all right with that being sad
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me